Worlds Collide In the Flesh and not
everyone survives The Experience he is
who's still standing by the time the
credits roll spoilers ahead for the
Flash
in a shocking turn of events the title
character of a superhero movie didn't
die coming up next time we'll get to the
bottom of whether or not water is still
wet in all seriousness maybe there was a
slight chance that Barry Allen wouldn't
make it to the end of his first solo
film after all this is technically
Barry's fourth appearance in the DC
Universe or fifth if you count on Zack
Snyder's Justice League so it's not like
they would off him before he got to
stretch his legs he's also unfortunately
and near inseparably tied to a
continuity in desperate need of a
drastic overhaul as well as an actor
whose actions have placed them in
understandably poor standing with fans
if you were going into the flash
thinking or perhaps even hoping that it
would be the end of Ezra Miller's time
and sights you wouldn't be completely
out of line yet she would still be very
wrong Barry not only survives the events
of the flash but emerges as a central
figure in the DC Universe whether or not
this film will fit into James Gunn's
rebooted Cinematic Universe remains to
be seen though if it does it's hard to
imagine just brushing this character
aside after such a heroic ending
the Batman of the flashpoint timeline
and presumably Tim Burton's Batman films
meets his end a number of times during
the quartets last stand against General
Zod he is first killed while trying to
take down a Kryptonian spacecraft only
to be brought back to life on the
Barry's travel backward despite his
resurrection and assisted avoidance of
his original death he is killed again
shortly afterward by one of zod's
soldiers Flashpoint Barry is unable to
accept any of the casualties they suffer
in the battle and continues resetting
and retrying to save the world and his
friends from the Kryptonian Invasion it
can thus be assumed that Michael
Keaton's Batman died hundreds if not
thousands of times not that it matters
considering his very existence as a
raised by original recipe Barry when he
finally resets the timeline but the bad
girl banished the Oblivion of unreleased
media and Michael Keaton becoming less
and less plausible as a vigilante it's
probably safe to say that this is the
last we'll see of Tim Burton's Batman it
was truly nerds while it lasted
like Michael Keaton's Batman the
flashpoint variant of Supergirl is also
murdered numerous times during the
infinitely reset battle against the
kryptonians she seems to primarily meet
her end or trying to defeat zard in
one-on-one combat despite the resetting
of the timeline however it isn't known
whether or not this version or rather a
similar one still played by Sasha Kaye
remains on the post-flash point era
there will however be at least some
iteration of the character in James
Gunn's DC Universe as he has already
announced the development of a feature
film titled Supergirl woman of tomorrow
if there are any winners in the
flashpoint zero it would be General Zod
after getting his neck stamped by
pre-flushpoint Superman and Man of Steel
after a horribly messy attempt at
terraforming Earth the Kryptonian
Warrior is able to return once more to
exacta's master plan for world
domination this world must die though
it's curiously glanced over by the plus
it seems as though zod's victory in the
flashpoint timeline is inevitable as
there are no Heroes powerful enough to
stop him as such he sort of serves in
the place of Aquaman and Wonder Woman's
nuclear war from the comics in that it's
an apocalyptic event that forces a flash
to see the error of his ways
unfortunately fazard Barry resets the
timeline assuming Michael Shannon is as
apathetic about returning to the
characters he appears to be it appears
as though this version of zardus finally
met his permanent end
as if the flash won't Bleak enough it
gives us a DC universe's first confirmed
child murder when Supergirl finally
confronts General Zod he reveals that he
originally searched for the Kryptonian
codex within the body of an infant
survivor of the Dead Planet Carlisle the
last son of Krypton
turns out Zod unequivocally confirms
that he did in fact kill a baby version
of Superman in an attempt of fines the
Codex of course in this timeline the
Codex was transferred into Supergirl
instead so the baby murder was
ultimately pointless nevertheless with a
new timeline Comes A New Carlisle who
all see in James Gunn's Superman Legacy
oh Flashpoint Barry as a film portrays
him having a relationship with two
living and three parents apparently made
Barry a helpless child with no
appreciation for his family this is the
world where my mom lives that is until
he learns that pre-flash point Barry
wants to reset the timeline so that
their mom is killed as she apparently
should be this realization pushes a
young Barry to the edges of his sanity
sending him down a grim path the
consequences of which he's directly
confronted with and the dark flash
emerges from the speed force as a
possible future self seeing what will
happen if he can't accept accountability
from self and its actions Flashpoint
Barry sacrifices himself to kill dark
Flash
Barry sacrifices his life just so that
his benevolent future self can travel
back in time to set things right which
is to say make absolutely certain that
his mother Nora gets stabbed by a
vicious home Invader Osman Lee Barry
succeeds sharing one last tender moment
with her before sending her home to a
death there is a slight chance she might
return some time down the line after all
we still have yet to learn the identity
of her killer if it turns out to be a
Speedster of some kind like the reverse
flash or Professor Zoom future films May
revisit her death through flashbacks
other than that Nora Allen is As Dead As
Parr Kent the Wayne's and every single
version of Uncle Ben
what is apparently crucial that Nora
Allenby killed the timeline doesn't seem
to care much about whether or not
Barry's dad Henry stays in prison
thankfully Barry picks up on this we
make sure that his father can
unwittingly look into a security camera
and confirm his alibi what is possible
that he might have been eventually freed
from prison by Barry Allen in the
pre-flash points Universe this timeline
shift means that he didn't spend years
of his life in prison for a crime he
didn't commit so at least something good
came from Barry's time meddling now for
one of the most tragic yet inevitable
casualties of the Flash's reset timeline
Ben Affleck's Bruce Wayne one of the
founding players in Zack Snyder's take
on the DC Universe Affleck's Batman was
often the highlight of any style of film
he was in it's no secret that he had
long desire to play the character before
receiving the offer and it's been
rumored that he was both surprised and
hurt by the critical panning of Batman v
Superman dawn of Justice yet even in the
poorest reviews our Flex performance and
fight scenes were still praised
following his Rocky dceu debut Affleck's
own Batman film dissolved as the writing
on the wall became clearer and clearer
that Snyder's Vision will need a plastic
rework to move forward years later when
gun was announced as a new head of DC
films the director stated on Twitter
that Affleck was in talks to direct a
film in the new slate only for the actor
to publicly shut this notion down as of
now the flash will be the final time
fancy was some considered to be the
greatest version of Batman on screen
after Barry's reset of the timeline
Affleck's Batman is definitively erased
I could fix things you could also
destroy everything
if we can't have Ben Affleck or Michael
Keaton at least the flash brings back
another shocking Batman George Clooney's
Bruce Wayne fresh from Joel Schumacher's
Batman and Robin after Barry manages to
exonerate his dad he's greeted on the
courthouse steps by a salt and pepper
Wayne who seemingly separated from both
the Schumacher verse and the snyderverse
we still don't have confirmation if
Clooney's appearance it's just meant to
be a fun Cameo or a genuine debut of the
new Batman if the latter is true that
would mean Clooney would presumably be
on board for James Gunn's to Brave in
the bold a new Batman film that would
follow the Caped Crusader and his young
formerly estranged son Damien whatever
the case Clooney is currently the post
Flashpoint Batman
the last big winner of The Flash is the
pre-flush point off a curry Aquaman who
despite being briefly erased in the
timeline during the events of the film
gets returned to his former glory
seemingly unaltered he appears in the
film's mid-credits scene in which he
drunkenly falls into a deep puddle or
barrier attempts to explain the new
Bruce Wayne to him more the scene is
strangely one of the funniest moments in
the entire film his purpose is pretty
transparent whatever the actual
intentions are for this weird
interregnum of the DC Cinematic Universe
the Warner Brothers top brass wants
audiences to feel like these films
matter so they need to do everything
they can to convince you that they're
still connected to both the future and
the past of the DC Universe if the
audience begins to smell a reboot coming
especially before the release of a film
like the reportedly troubled Aquaman in
the lost kingdom that could be
disastrous for its box office potential
so for now and for the sake of ticket
sales pre-flash Point Aquaman is here to
stay
[Music]